♪♪
-In 1973,
The Allman Brothers Band
was one of the most
prominent touring rock acts
in the country.
Fresh off the release of
their third album,
they returned to the studio in
search of their next sound.
It was during this time that
founding member Dickey Betts
wrote what would soon become
one of their biggest hits.
"Ramblin' Man" quickly became
an American classic,
peaking at number 2 on
the Billboard Hot 100 chart
and earning its place as one of
the greatest rock songs
of all time.
But America never heard
its first draft...until now.
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ Lord, I was born
a ramblin' man ♪
♪ Tryin' to make a livin' and
doin' the best I can ♪
♪ And I was born in the
back seat of a Greyhound bus ♪
♪ I was born ramblin' man ♪
♪ Like I said,
I was born in a Greyhound ♪
♪ The people
on the bus were like,
"Hey, what's that noise?" ♪
♪ Some guy yelled, "I think that
a lady's giving birth ♪
♪ In the back seat
of this Greyhound bus ♪
♪ The bus driver screamed,
"Wait, should I pull over?" ♪
♪ A few people on board said,
"No, just drive ♪
♪ But a couple
other people said,
"You gotta park this bus" ♪
♪ The driver did not
park the bus ♪
♪♪
-♪ I knew you were born
a ramblin' man ♪
♪ But I didn't know about the
bus birth till just now ♪
♪ I'd kinda prefer
we sing about anything else ♪
♪ But I'm also weirdly curious ♪
-♪ Well, if you've got
a question, you can ask it ♪
♪ And I'll try to remember
details from that 'Hound ♪
-♪ I don't even
know where to start ♪
♪ I guess,
how much did you weigh? ♪
-♪ Somewhere between
6 and 20 pounds ♪
-♪ 20 pounds
is too big for a baby ♪
♪ I wanna say
the average is like 8 ♪
-♪ Well, it ain't like they had
a scale on that bus ♪
♪ That was just an estimate ♪
♪♪
-♪ Now, did your mother
name you on that Greyhound? ♪
-♪ Well, she named me after
the driver of that bus ♪
♪ His name was Nicky Bus ♪
-♪ But your name is
Dickey Betts ♪
-♪ That's 'cause she wrote
the name down wrong ♪
-♪ Dickey Betts was born
on a Greyhound ♪
♪ Dickey Betts
was born on a Greyhound ♪
♪ Dickey Betts was born
on a Greyhound bus ♪
♪ Dickey Betts
was born on a bus ♪
♪♪